thanks for joining us Katelyn is with us
in Tampa hi Kaitlyn how are you good I'm
so happy to talk to you you too how can
I help
I'm a little bit overwhelmed because I
just I was told by my coworker about you
and somewhere I was watching your videos
the more I realized how out of control
me and my husband were with our money
and we I don't know where to start like
I've already made a budget and I well I
think I made a good budget and I talked
to my husband we're on the same page
that we want to be debt-free and have a
house but there's so many things that
according to the different videos of
watched viewers but I also notice that
we don't have done like a good nest egg
or we don't have an investment I don't
have a 401k he does and our savings is
only like 2,500 okay what's your
household income I think the total is
like around 100 thousand wow that's
great how old are you guys I'm 27 he's
29
perfect and how much debt do you have
not counting your house oh I don't have
a house 23,000 for the student loan and
car total and a few thousand and medical
I think around 3,500 and then I think
like a thousand something for our phone
okay all right well what we teach folks
to do is like you said to do a budget we
use a we have a budget system out that's
free to use called every dollar you can
download it from at night you can
download it for your iPhone your Android
every dollar calm or you know um you
know in the app store whatever you want
to do and I'll help you build your
budget in about ten minutes you and your
husband look that over when you do a
written budget usually you feel like
you've got a raise because you're like
where is all this money going you're
going to discover that you're wasting
money you're gonna discover the money is
going to disorganization and so on now
when you do that then we find money
in the budget what are our first goals
we have a process we teach called the
baby steps and that's the first thing to
do the second thing to do the third
thing to do one baby step at a time your
first baby step is to save a thousand
dollars well you've already done that
check your at twenty five hundred right
okay then baby step two just take
everything above a thousand dollars in
any non retirement savings or
investments and we're gonna throw it at
your debt and we're gonna throw anything
else we can find in the budget towards
your dad listing your debts smallest to
largest pay off balance and paying
minimum payments on everything but the
little one attacking the little one with
a vengeance when it is paid off you go
to the next one when that one's paid off
you go to the next one when that one's
paid off you go to the next one it
sounds to me like you've got about
thirty thousand dollars worth of debt
with $100,000 income you should be
debt-free and a touch over a year that's
twenty five hundred bucks and does that
mean that after that then I save for the
house or do I see for the retirement or
go to baby step three which is a fully
funded emergency fund we raised that one
thousand dollars up to a proper rainy
day fund which is three to six months of
expenses then after three is where
people start saving for houses we always
call saving for a house maybe step three
B because four is 15% of your income
going into retirement so sometimes after
you get your emergency fund in place
before you start saving for retirement
some people will pause right there for a
year and save up a good down payment on
your saving up a good down payment on
your house and you know that's what we
call baby step three B and Kaitlin the
book that outlines all of this that you
know on the bestseller list for hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of weeks is
called the Total Money Makeover and I'll
send you a copy of it free you hold on
and you and your husband go through that
book together get on every dollar and
get your budget going and we'll show you
exactly
what to do step by step the baby steps
on steroids that's what the Total Money
Makeover basically is it's exactly what
to do and why to do it in what order and
it'll show you know there's no question
the only question is whether you're
going to do it if you do it it'll work
100% of the time